E S CAPTEDE VIDEOS SHOW EXOSIONS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED ILASTUSANCRIR
EN RUSSIAN AIR BASE
RESPONLITY FOR THAT ATTACK
LAUNCHING A COUNTEROFFEN RNMENT
AG?
ANCOBAILLEGALLY OVERN OSCOW?
G ME NOW IRETIRE
ANT THIS RAL MARNATIONAL SECITDY
MORNING.
>> GREAT TO BE O MORNINGLET'ROLD
STW D HOW MUF TB THIS RU
>>
HAPPENING WITH UAIFIELD,OFHA DSE
IN SIKND PR D OFUST EYMORES WHIT
ENEMY K FOOT AND VERE OPIOTURE.
AND FIIMATU , AS YOU WEL BEEN W
MORALE F ATY OF O HAVE TEIB
ERS HA,
ROS,AS TO THE RIG    MISSION.
HESE ATTACKSFUHE
N E
IMPROVING THE UKRAINIA
HEECATTACK.
>> PREDENT H A THE SOUTH.
ARE THESE EN AD
KHERSON FOR INSTANCE -D THEYD TN
>> CAN S AF THE
IN U PRECISEAG
ABOUT RGVE KIN
FORCESN'T SEE INIAN
IAN ARMYT I E OVERR SURE, I STI
PABILITY
L  CCT
ST, UE TO T,
COUNRAWI
.
IN KHERSONOTTHE SOUTH.'S M
BILLION DOLLARSSISTAR UKRA INCLT
THEY DESCRIBE THIS AS
POTENTIA CHANGER
, THE E
ABTOBEDEPOTS, ET CETERA.
BE AL TO THE EFFT WEG AMIT
SAW OF JAVELINNTI-TANKILES THEYH
RE RIG.
MILLIONACELER, THE MOST RECENTO
HIMARS ROCKET PODS, WHICTE
T H EI
TARGETS.
FOMA
HEA T
PHTHREE,HILE VES, SOME OF T THTA
E E
ARMY T OU.
AND IT'S DFERE.SO HAVE  L O ANTN
MINE CLEARG F.SOE OF
RUIAEY ATTAC
RN PLA YEAH, THAS PACKAGE,
GIAN WHAE
U.S. AKRAINIS E XT PHAE WALLLIK.
A SEE THIS OPEN,
COS IS G AROUNPE LNUCLEA.AR CIRI
DELIBERATE BY IA, THT  ISESOMETR
ZHOWER PLANT IS  EHO
ARAT WE
.
POWER
E N E KINDEYAKWIRO
MANY TIMD STILL, THEECTS OF NUC.
Y TO, SE UEYNG
TE
BUT ILISDANGERA
MILIRY IS A CIVILIAR
COULD HURTIS IS SOMETHG
POY